I will defeat this game
if it's the last thing I'll ever do..
This game is easy ok
If you haven't played this game it's a piece of cake.
This cake is- it's not a very delicious cake
but it's a cake.
That needs to be eaten
ALIVE
First you got to make sure you go up here
right okay alright
Slow down there cowboy we're not speedrunning it~
Now we got to get up to   the rake
which you might think
"oh that's impossible"
it's actually super easy.
now THIS bit
you want to go out as far as possible
and you want to pendulum swing
and that actually makes the slide 20 times eazier
a lot of people struggle on the slide
NØŦ ĐƗS ǤUɎ
there's another one of those where you
just have to launch yourself
and right before you go
YOU'RE GONNA AAAAAAA
THAT'S HOW ITS DONE
So what you want to do is
you want to grab the hammer heAre
ᵃⁿᵈ ʸᵒᵘ ʷᵃⁿⁿᵃ ᵍᵒ 𝗱𝗼𝘄𝗻 very slowly
Vewy nice
Oh god! That's not slow.
Bu- you're not going slow right now buddy
Oh you oh no you- I made a terrible...
OH look at that
Oh look at that
You thought I made a terribLE mihftake
(mistake w/ his shitty swedish accent jk)
j̶u̶s̶t̶ ̶s̶h̶u̶t̶ ̶t̶h̶e̶ ̶f̶u̶c̶k̶ ̶u̶p̶
Now we're gonna do the same trick
as we have done before
nooow I've only- AH~ MY GOD okay
we're just gonna
we're just gonna fucking- PRRRRRRRA
THAT'S WHAT IT MEANS to be a ~ AAAAAAAAAAAAAA
NO!! NO FUCK YOU!
[laugh, and the world laughs with you.]
FUCK YOU THEN
[Weep, and you weep alone.]
[For the sad old-]
IDIDIDIDIDI would you- can you be quiet?
Can I turn him off?
Can I turm in off???
oh wow the game just became better
OH
OH hello
What's up?! What's up?!!
fuck you
What's up everybody it's-yA boi
fuUUᵘck
oh god what have I done?
AAAH look at that SKILL
look at that skiiiill babah
game journalist little 5000 right there (??)
WUOAH
POwer move
POWER mo-
...
POWER MOVE
ᴾᴼᵂᴱᴿ ᴹᴼⱽᴱ (??)
Hell yeah man!! You killin' it Felix
OOH
OOOOOOOH (look at his tougue)
NO (omg my ears)
𝕨𝕙𝕒𝕥'𝕤 𝕘𝕠𝕠𝕕 𝕖𝕧𝕖𝕣𝕪𝕓𝕠𝕕𝕪 𝕙𝕖𝕪 𝕓𝕠𝕪 *moaning*
"Pewds you're using macros"
Shut the fuck up
excuse me the door is ringing
(pewds butt has gone away with his dignity)
oh hi  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
(the visitor is IMPACIENT (the doorbell rang 2 times))
(caution phone users)
(i warned ya)
(THREE TIMES NOW)
(wait. Is it a bell?)
I'm the best goddamn gamer on YouTube.
lift me up... like- fuck and- dammit! It's so FRUSTRATING
*laughs*
I have no control. I'm just like waving my foot
(look at his mouth, again)
SUCK ON MY fucking toes (?)
*unintelligible groanings*
(Pewds you ok?)
GET UUUUUUP
Can YoU SUck a DICK?
My god like
Oh my go-
He just prrramlehaha
oh wow
no
(mouth)
(again)
nO
I'm so fucking-
oh my GOD. OH. MY. GAH.
this stupid (c/g)rumbling little thing in the mouse
and my gggGOD
'kay
right
How in the world do I get up from there?
I keep- doesn't fucking going anywhere
No. We do not go down there.
No.
We talked about this. Oh my god it, it-
I'm sweating so much.
This stupid guy
No. RELAX.
New strat. New strat. New strat. (strategy)
That will PIERC- nOO. No!! Oh god.
ahh fuck
New strat.
What the fuck, like, launch yourself woman
Did I just hear someone using microaggression?
whoa whoa whoa
what just happened? What just happened?
How did I do that?
oh my god omae wa mou shindeiru (You're already dead in Japanese)
Can I just sit here? Can I just sit here?
You know... You know they tell you
you hear bells ringing before you die
*bells ringing*
I can't tell if it's real life or the game at this point
oh oh oh
no NO
NO
NOOO
We fight BACK OOH oh
ah ah ah ah
(?? r u alright?)
Oh god oh my god OH WOW
Oh-kay
Okay we're on the toilet
Sitting on a toilet
(we lost him)
Oh huh
shut up music
BEST GAMER ON YOUTUBE
Didn't you think i could get it didn't you
"Oh he's never going to beat this."
easy.
EASY.
now we going down BABE. Goin down~~
It's gonna be easy.
What the heck is this?
My body is shaking
What what's up everybody
Oh what? No. No. No. no no you can't be serious
What happens down there?
Do I have to go up there? if I fall
what happens if I fall down?
You're so mean
whoever made this. Bennett you're so mean
let's just push away this orange. Go away.
Can we push this out a little bit as well?
No that's frozen. Okay
oh wow
There's no checkpoints
there is no checkpoint
That's so mean
You're mean~
oh wow okay
It's so steep.
It's seriously so steep.
Oh wow oh wow look at that look at that everybody
it's your boy PewDiePie I'm gonna cry
oh my god it gets steeper
(stop crying)
It's just not fair
it's just not fair
oh my god it gets even worse
Oh my god
[you know they tell you
you hear bells ringing before you die]
NOOOOoooo